Joe Biden has a much stronger image
abroad than Donald Trump in just about
every country now you might remember
when I was on the Patrick Bet David show
I brought this up and I said hey you
know I mean we we are much more
respected now with Joe Biden as the
president than we were under Trump and I
mentioned that the Gallup survey
regularly shows that well multiple
surveys are actually showing this as
well including a new one from morning
consult and if you look at this and you
look at any place from Australia Brazil
and Canada all the way down to the
United Kingdom and Japan and Kenya the
net favorability for Joe Biden versus
Donald Trump blows Trump out of the
water